बुडि र कुखुरा
यस कथा का कथा लेखाक हुनु हुन्छा करुनाकर बैधा
एका देश मा एक टी साराइने गरी बुडि थीहिन, भिचारी कु कोई पनी थीहिनान
जंगल मा गएरा दाउरा खोजी गाउ मा लगेरा बेजदाई बड़ो मुष्किले उनि आकनु पेट पाल थी
एक दिन, तेसे गरी उनले जंगल मा दाउरा खोजना जादा उनले जाडी मा कुखुरा को एक ता फूल बेटा हिन
साइद बनाया कुखुरा को फूल थीहो, उसले ते फूल घरमा लगेरा बड़ो जतले राखिन
केही दिन पछी ते फूल राखेको ठाओ बाता उनले कुखुरा को चल्ला को आवास सुलिन
गएर रहे दा उनले एटा खुबे राम्रो रहर लाग दो कुखुरा को चल्ला देखिन, बुडि ले ते स्चल्ला लाई आफो न खायारा भाई पनि जुट्यूँ गरी हुरका हिन
एक दिन ते कुखुरा को चल्लो फूलो बहयो अनि ते कुखुरो ले बुडि आमा तिमी संगा पैसा छा बनि देउना पसल बाता केही किनेरा लियाँसो भनियो
कुखुरा ले मांचेले जस्ते बोलेको सुन्दा बुडि छक्का परिं अनि आफोले बडो मुष्किले बचाई राखिको एक पैसा जिकेरा दिइन
पसले दाई पसले दाई मले जहट्टै एक पैसा को चामल दीनुस्ता अनि पसले परि छक्का परियरा भनियो एक पैसा को चामल कति आँसा राखिको धापा केमलानी
अनि कुखरा ले भनियो मेरो कान को पवाल मा जत्ति अटाँसा तितीने राखि दियो अनि पसले ले बनी तिति सान पवाल मा कतिने अटाँलारा बन्ने सोचेरा उनले हुँछ अ भनेरा कुखरा को कान मा चामल आल् psychiatrist दालियो तर कि अच्छमण पसले को चामल ले भ
यो तिम्रो पैसे फ्योता लियो अनि मेरा सब्पे चामल फ्योता गर आ
उकखरा ले पनी हुँछ बनेरा अपनो पैसय पहले नहीं लियरा
अलिकती चामल खणायरा भुर्र उडियो
गहर कुकेरा उखरा ले बन्यो
बुडी आमा बुडी आमा थांग खाछ गरा
भूडी ले पणि उकख्रा ले बनीग रस्त्ते गरं
अ नि कुख्रा ले अपनो कान बैंटा चामल खणिआ उनथालेयो
तिह बूडी को साना छुपटी चामल ले बढ़ियो
फेरी कुख्रा उडेर एउड़ा डाल को पसंग मा पुगियो
तेशला पणि उसले चामल पसले ले जही ठगी
बुडी को घर में डाल को थूपरो लगाई दियो
तेसे गरी तेश कुख्रा ले एक पैशा ले
नून, तेल, मसाला, आधि इत्याति चाहिणी जति हरे थूप जम्मा गर्यो
अनि तिने बस्तोहर को साहिता ले बुडी रा कुख्रा दुबै मिली दर्बार जस्त एउटा ठूलो घर बनायो
त्यो बुडी महारैनी जस्ते बहिसकी कि थिन
धन सम्पति पणि कुनै राजा को बन्दा कम थियेना
तेस पची एक दिन त्यो कुख्रा तेस देश को राजा को छोरी संगा बिहे गरना भनी हिल्डियो
जदा जदा तेसले बाटम मा एउटा माउरी को जुम्रा बेटायो
अनि ती माउरी हरू ले बने
कुख्रप मा वया हमों दुन doesn't hear
कुख्रा दाई कुख्रा दाई काहं जाना लागेगो
अनी खूख्रा ले बनौ
जुम्रा ताना राजा को छोरी संगा बिहे गरना
अनि माउरी हरू ले बने
हमि ला पनि तपाई संगय ळे जानूस ना
बरु तपाई को कुने काम मा लागने छो
अनि कुख्रा ले पनि माउरी हरू सबई लाई अपनो कान भितर राखेर लग्यो
जादा जादा उसले एक तूलो पोखरी बेटायो
अनि त्यो पोखरी ले उसलाई सोडियो
कुख्रा दाई कुख्रा दाई कता हिडेगो
अनि कुख्रा ले बनियो राजा को ठोरी संगгर बिखे गरणा
अनि पोखरी को पानि ले बनियो मला पनि संगरले जाउणा
शायद मा तपई को कुने काम लागने सक्छो कि
अनि कुख्रा ले पनि पोखरी को पानिलाई रान मा राखेर लग्यो
तिष दाउरा ले पनि तेही प्रस्णा गर्यो
अनि फेरी कुख्रा ले बनियो राजा को ठोरी संगगर बिखे गरणा
अनि दाउरा को आगले बनियो मलाई पनि तपई संगरले जाउणा
साइठ मॉ तपय कुख पुने काम लाँगन सक्छु कि
अनि कुख्रा ले बनियो कहीं तेमिலे मलाई पली दियो बैनेनी
अनि दाउरा को आगले बनीव मह बातत तपयले किइपं भनी
पनि पुख्रा ले अपना कानाई को छोँमा राखेरा लग्यो
एक सिन पचि त्यो कुख्रा राजगो दर्बार मा फुगियो
और उडेर एक ता रुक को हाँगा मा बसियो
तियो दिन राजगो छोडि को विभा हुना लागेको थीयो
चारे तिरा निके चालपल और खुशियाली देखिन थियो
तेस बेला कुख्रा ले कराऊँते पालेला बन्यो
ए द्वारपाल मा राजगो छोडि संगा बिही गर्ना आयेको हुँ
लाता चाड़े राज़ा ले खबर गरि दियो
कुख्रा को कुखरा सुनियरा पहले तो द्वारपालन अशे
तर पछी देशले केह सिपाय हरू बलायरा कुख्राले धपाउना लागायो
अनि कुख्राले पनि बड़ो फूर्तिका साथ
माउरी भायो, सिपाय सबई को सिर खाई दियो ता
बनेका मात्र की थियो माउरी हरू को एक शुन्दा ले
भुनुनु गरदै सिपाय हरू ले टोकना धालेयो
बिचारा हरू डर ले कराऊदै सबै कुरा राजालै निवेदन गरना पुगे
राजाले पनि गजब मान दै कुख्राले बुलाउना पठाये
तर कुख्रा भने अपनो धाम बड़ा पिटिक्क पणि चलेना
अन्त्यमा धारमानी राजा सोयम नहीं हाँती माथी चलेरा
कुख्रा भहे तिरा आय भुगयो
राजालै देखेरा कुख्राले बड़ो आदारगा साप पन्यो
राजा हजुर, मुझा अजुरको छोरी संग बिहे गरना भनि आयको हुँ
अजुरको छोरी संग मेरो बिभा गरी दिनु होस
अनि राजा इक्टम संग जंगियर भने
तों जस्तो जाबे एउटा बनोट जिप संग मा अपना परम सुन्दरी छोरी को बिभा गरी दिनु
एधि तों अपना बलो चाहन्छस मने यहा बाता भाग, नतरा तेरे ज्यान रहने छैना
अनि कुख्रा मात्रा किन कम होतियो रा
अनि कुख्रा ले पनि आगोलाई संबोधन गर्डई राजा को महल जलाउने आदेश दियो
कुख्रा ले हुकुम मात्रा के दिये का थे राजा को दर्बार उने के अगाली बलन थालियो
सबै भाई भादार हरु इस्तेरे पुरुष कोलाहल गर्डई जता तताई भागना थाले
राजा ले आगो निबाउने लाखो कोशिष गरे
तर आगो जनजन चर्तु हुदै दंकिदै गयो
अन्त्यमा राजा ले हार मानी कुख्रा संगा अपनो छोरी को बिभा गरि दिने बाचा गरे
तेस पची कुख्रा ले पानी लाई आगो निबाउने आदिश दियो
कुरोन तै आगो निब्यो और पैले को बहन्दा पणि रामन्र दर्बार खड़ा भयो
अनि राजा ले बड़ो धुमदाम का साथ कुख्रा संगा अपनो छोरी को बिभा गरि दिये
अनि कुख्रा राजकुमारी बाबा लसकार का साथ बाजा बजाउँड़े अकनो घर पुग्यो
आपोले राजकुमारी बुहारी पाएको देखि बोडि पणि दंग न परिन
तेस दिन देखि तिनै जाना अनेक नोकर चाकर भाई भार्धार हरुली गहरियर अनन्द पुर्बक बसना थाले